we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
nice little question from the audience
let's take a listen i love answering
these questions uh yeah i was wondering
if you support communism which is
basically social anarchism based on
common ownership of the means of
production yeah with money being
abolished at all that's all uh I do not
support communism I do not and why do
you think we get asked so often whether
I support communism like I feel like
every time this comes up I say I am a
supporter of well regulate regulated
capitalist economies a sort of like the
Scandinavian models that we see and yet
maybe it's my suits maybe it's my hair I
don't know what it is but I constantly
am answering this question or am I a
socialist am i a communist I'm not yeah
I mean how does a caller watch the show
every day see us talk about politics and
economics and all of these different
topics and come away with it thinking
that maybe you are a commie
I really don't have to call in just to
make sure it's the frequency with which
we get that question is stunning to me
and if somebody can explain it to me I
it's it's not because I'm Jewish is it
right like I don't I don't even want to
open up that door because that's another
thing like the stereotypical Jewish
communist I don't think you wear a red
shirt on the program I know I don't even
think I owned a red shirt nevermind wear
a red shirt on the program please tell
me why it is that so many people think I
might be a communist all right we've got
a great bonus show for you today I don't
even have time to tell you what's on it
but trust me it's a good one access it
by becoming either a member or a patron
and we will speak to you then